when conan was in he he told us the
story about how he they
they sent you and conan into a room with
george steinbrenner
and conan said that george steinbrenner
you you had a pitch on the sketch and he
basically just sat there and yelled at
you guys for
and like you guys
is that right why jeremy irons well
because
rob schneider and i had written this
monologue i think
and it was a great
he was right he was really mad
as a writer what is the the scenario you
walk in
i mean i've got this
you have me doing this i can sing
i can dance i can juggle
i'm a shakespearean trained actor and
you have me doing this
and he was really mad and howard i
taped it i taped him i had a little i
had a little recorder
because i loved it so much and he was he
was right
god bless him it wasn't a great
monologue
buddy did you play it for everyone the
tape do you just play it for yourself
for many people i don't know where it is
now it's at the bottom of them
that's the greatest thing it exists are
you proud of that i mean do you do you
sort of take a pride that you've been
yelled at by some of the best yes